dit mir 13 ans est un miraculé le 26
février dernier deux jours après le
début de la guerre en ukraine la voiture
dans laquelle il se trouvait a été
criblée de balles son père et son cousin
ont tous les deux été tués lors de
l'attaqué
son visage était blessé sa mâchoire
était cassé son mais aussi
sa jambe touchée à deux endroits sombres
a aussi et il y avait une ou deux balles
dans le dos je me souviens plus nous
n'avons pas réalisé qu'ils tiraient dès
que tout sera terminé nous
redécouvrirons et ils seront punis
depuis le jeune garçon est soigné dans
cet hôpital pédiatrique de kiev le plus
grand du pays
depuis le début de la guerre nous
traitons des personnes blessées des
enfants et des adultes aussi
blessé par des missiles des balles et
des roquettes
ici la plupart du personnel soignant
reste disponible 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 c'est vraiment horrible sur
le plan émotionnel c'est affreux nous
vivons à l'hôpital nous ne rentrons plus
chez nous certains évoquent déjà l'après
guerre est pour eux un soutien
psychologique sera indispensable